thank you
[Music]
guys like Virgin Airlines yeah uh
depends the Australian one is like
spirit
the virgin in Australia is like budget
cheap airlines but then the Virgin
America is actually pretty nice didn't
they so
did they sell Alaska yeah I don't even
see their flights anymore really oh
really I saw a commercial for a virgin
recently it was like you know going
through they went through the cabinets
like every race Creed and color and then
they go to the they go to the um the
Pilot's chair and there's like this smug
white lady like being like like she's
getting her [ __ ] [ __ ] eaten she's
like flying the skies and it's like who
is this for
like who is this woman and her [ __ ] was
getting down yeah crazy you have to
watch it you have to see the smug look
on her face I wasn't I didn't I never
connected smug with getting your [ __ ]
eating yeah it's like a smug look on
your face like get down there [ __ ] and
get it right
oh that look so did you guys know that
Virgin Airlines let's um flight
attendants wear whatever gen like gender
neutral uniforms so like if if you
identify as a woman you can wear the
female uniform
but still I haven't been in Virgin
Airlines used to be male presenting if
that makes sense yeah I thought their
whole business went out during covid
zero Virgin Airlines they're still going
and I believe maybe some of them might
be private Chargers now I don't know but
um yeah they can pretty much uh be
gender neutral for their uniforms except
for this one time possibly what do you
think the exception is wearing lingerie
no I mean like they're like hey normally
I know you guys could do that but today
don't do that except Easter
um right now it's like a thing that's
going on right now Halloween
that's pretty good uh it's not a holiday
exposing too much cleavage because
that's the thing let's say it's let's
just say it has to do with the sport a
sport a sport can't wear football
jerseys and [ __ ] no uh they have to
dress like their biological gender
four flights to Qatar two Qatar oh yeah
yeah
you are good so this guy gets it you're
knocking [ __ ] over today so win Verge oh
so it's a Virgin Atlantic or whatever
the UK virgin flights are they're
probably still operating
so there's Virgin America Virgin
Atlantic Virgin Australia
they're the same company but ran
differently in three different places
Virgin America that disappeared and
you're talking about Virgin Atlantic
which is from the UK so it's probably a
UK flight or whatever yeah going to uh
uh Qatar right so the thing the focus on
the whole thing about Virgin allowing
this and then now they conducted like a
some kind of analysis
to see
if it's worth the safety of their crew
when they're traveling to Qatar whatever
yeah during the World Cup because what
if they arrive and they're like hey you
are cross-dresser and then they
put them to jail because they're like
you're a man you're wearing a skirt you
go to jail I think it's also the the
safety of like on the plane itself like
um they'll they might be dealing with
criticism that they don't deserve to
have to put up with uh yeah passengers
um
I know it's not too much about like once
they're in the country I think they just
advised against it because
would probably save a lot of trouble try
but
um they did say that uh the ambassador
of the Qatar World Cup he did say that
gay people whatever you're all welcome
as fans to come watch the game but
do not have public displays of affection
and then for a German broadcaster that
was interviewing him he said he called
homosexuality damage of the mind oh [ __ ]
so it's not it's like welcoming but not
in a way you know what I mean they're
like just don't show me that even so we
can correct you yeah yeah or it's like
it's like your parents it's like you're
you're gay and you're bringing like your
significant other home and your parents
aren't down it's like don't do it around
them yeah keep it outside platonic what
do you think of that what do you think
of it's we'll take your money but don't
be gay around us yeah yeah that's what
they're saying
what do you think come on down and spend
your good gay money but when it comes to
yeah you're showing your love yeah leave
it out of here yeah but what about
Virgin Airlines specifically what do you
think of their call to tell their uh
flight attendants hey I know you guys
can do this normally and we and we we
love supporting that but it's not a good
call this time so I go back to the it's
like your parents thing it's like hey
they're [ __ ] whack they're so whack
I'm sorry that we could do just be chill
about it yeah uh where do you balance
between human rights and what we believe
is morally right and also
thinking about when in Rome because like
there are religions like for example in
Sumo Sumo wrestling that's also
religious it's also a sport so on the
um stage women can't go on
it's just the old like religious
spiritual thing right and then so it's
kind of like a weird because they're not
they're modern in Japan but they also
are like that's [ __ ] weird because
not all of us are Shinto the religion
but then it's like also in this
situation too
um
we're actually in their country now by
the time you know so totally so like
what is what is the right thing to do
well I think I think that one in Rome is
a very very good way to put it right
it's like um because they were gay yep
they were they were so gay yes they were
hell okay weren't they yeah it's not
like the whole thing those are all
things the Romans that's what you're
trying to say right it can't no but who
gives a [ __ ] right
whatever
oh you want to hear it dude hear it no
no just just uh you know cosign what
he's saying like one room it's like
Brittany gretner in the [ __ ] drugs
right no matter how sympathetic we want
to be it's like well you brought drugs
into somebody else's country right so
same thing it's like they're they're
watching their employees backs they're
trying to protect them be like hey we're
flying to this country even if we
collectively don't necessarily agree
with the rules it's their rules we're
flying to the country so it's like we
should abide by them for your own safety
type stuff so it makes sense and it's
probably fair warning what about what it
it's not necessarily that they're going
to that country but that people of that
country are going to be using their
service and they don't want to upset the
people that are giving them the money
because it's not what if it's not so
much that they're going to Qatar at all
but it's more like hey when we're in the
air don't let these people who are
paying
deal with this that they the thing they
don't like in their country even though
they're not necessarily they're still in
airspace like is that fair to be like
titties dude
like yeah because they're not you're not
in their country anymore yeah but you're
an international airspace if you're with
your girlfriend or some [ __ ] you can't
like like just kiss on the cheek or
nothing or like whatever you're doing
because this is during the flight
then what what does it even have to do
with Qatar if you're not going to their
country they are going to Qatar but
while they're on the plane at all oh
yeah but that's what I'm saying like
you're going to Qatar it's like um
like if I'm going to any other country
chances that let like if I go to [ __ ]
India or something like that there's
probably going to be a bunch of Indian
people on the plane right right so I'm
not gonna like I don't know do anything
that's offensive to any people just
because I'm in international waters
that's all and I think that that's me
being considerate not necessarily uh
having to be like an absolute right and
wrong in the situation yeah you
shouldn't have to I should have how
about them be considered to American me
that's that's the part that like damn it
that's why I'm gonna bomb them and bring
democracy because they need to learn
freedom and now you can vote you lucky
sons of [ __ ] then if I'm from Guitar
why what am I doing choosing that
Airline exactly yeah that's not the only
Airline that's going to Qatar you know
what I'm saying so it's like if I'm
jumping on Virgin and everybody
understands even without this dress code
everybody knows virgin is like that
other type of Airline they got the
cooler lights they got the different
party Vibes right yeah so if you're
gonna go on the airline that's what
you're paying for otherwise go to Qatar
Airways go Delta dude they you don't
want to be on there anyway
I
100 yeah that's where the debate kind of
the debate kind of lands there is like
why is the compromise one-sided but also
the it's because the financials are
one-sided it's like these people are
paying for this so we're accommodating
them versus like hey
um yeah we're gonna take your money but
we're gonna you know encroach on your
own personal values look at Chinese
money and movies dude it's the same
exactly yeah don't cut anything that has
to do with gay or anything like that oh
for sure and launch it in China and then
over here they'll they'll they're gonna
lecture you if you don't want to play
the movie but then they sell it to China
it's [ __ ] hilarious exactly yeah how
involved do you think companies should
be in these types of conversations
because they're just providing a service
can't we just leave it at that I
understand like the the situation may
arise in certain you know
um circumstances beyond that but I mean
it's like people getting mad at a
certain company for not supporting
something that they want them to support
but it's like I'm just a company in
providing a service yeah but I want to
know if Doritos is down with the cost I
need to know if Doritos is lgbtq
friendly because when I take a bite out
of the chip I want to taste diversity
I like I do like what they did because
it's like yeah virgin normally hey you
guys can do what you want this is your
identity you can wear your identity of
course but they said like literally we
conducted research and we think the risk
is too high for your safety doing this
job so it's they're telling them like
hey it's not us it's like just for the
you know the good of everyone's
experience like maybe you don't want to
do that this time and it's like it is
good advice unless the conversations
open yeah and also they don't have to
work that flight yeah they don't have
you know I think like there's so many
outs for both sides like the customers
don't have to fly version the flight
attendants can book a different flight
you know the ones that don't mind
dressing in their biological like birth
gender
they can probably work that flight and
then there's a compromise for that
specific situation because I think what
happens is like you can't force someone
your moral right if especially if
millions of people believe this you just
have to figure a compromise because then
we've been doing this forever where
America
comes up with some ideal of how the
world should be and then they try to
pressure others to do it right as long
as a human rights like violation isn't
being like you know done and and people
aren't going to jail for cross-dressing
or whatever then what the [ __ ] but even
on the other side too like like you know
if a guy doesn't want to bake a cake for
a gay wedding
I say you send in the [ __ ] SWAT team
put a gun to his head
you break him do it or you make an
example exactly exactly you make that
damn that's always the best case man
yeah it happens still all the goddamn
time it happens every every couple
months still yeah I mean that's when it
comes to like like peer-to-peer
consumerism like that that happens with
even [ __ ] emotional support dogs yeah
it's like you won't let my dog in I
think this business should [ __ ] close
now it's the best and it's a [ __ ]
Korean barbecue it's like yeah your
dog's gonna be snarling taking a [ __ ] in
the middle of the restaurant exactly
it's like come on man
foreign